help us change the culture by buying our
latest single from tim cast records only
ever wanted by clicking the link in the
description below
let's jump to this story from
timcast.com white house double doubles
down on biden's semi-fascism claim about
maga republicans
there you know this is this is a it's
sad it's pathetic that baiden said this
that uh karine jean-pierre jean-pierre
bronson reaffirmed it uh
but it is kind of worrying when the
president is now starting to embrace
the extremist rhetoric it's one thing
when he said he was going to be a great
uniter and bring bill together and now
he's continually doing the exact
opposite it makes me worried about
what he wants what the what the
establishment wants for this country
was that was that in reference to the
tweet that he put up or his his team his
handlers put up about pissing off moms
like the mega republicans have pissed
off them he said they were semi
embracing semi-fascism okay so this is a
separate tweet but it's like oh here we
go yeah that's that's the thing dude
it's like it's it's the continued
gaslighting you know you almost get
exhausted talking about it it's like we
know these people are the fascists
they're the ones that are pro lockdown
they're the ones that are you know
hailing the fbi going after their
political enemies they're the ones that
are literally calling to swat marjorie
taylor green and we know they died three
times three times and like oh there's a
trans person's life a trans person's
life is in danger like literally we know
why they're doing it because they want
her to get shot
what happened was is that what they
claimed at her house they said the 9-1-1
call they said it was a trans person at
her house
wow but i think this is like a deeper
issue too right it's like this idea that
your political opponent doesn't just
disagree with you
because they disagree with you and the
things that they disagree with you on
makes them an evil person it makes them
reprehensible it makes them that we
can't be part of the same country and
you saw this with with kathy hokel in
new york too recently where she was
telling her constituents that voted red
or voted for the right the republican
get on an airplane get on a bus and go
down to florida where you belong because
you're not a new yorker and so it's like
it's like this winner-take-all kind of
mindset in politics that if we win then
everybody else that voted against us is
a terrible human being and i don't want
to share a country with you right it's
not just you voted different because you
may live in upstate new york and you're
a farmer and you have different
prerogatives and different uh you know
things that you care about it's you're
an evil person
what is semi-fascism
you know i think it is i think if what
does that even mean it means if he came
out and said fascist he'd have nowhere
to go
so he needs to be able to one-up it so
now in 2023 24 in election season he's
gonna be like they've gone to full
fascism now yeah but that was that was
2016 and 2020. yeah but now he's talking
about the regular people
he it's it's like they're trying to find
a way to to go away from trump and then
take whatever the anger they had towards
trump and apply it to everyone well they
already did this with the um you know
the moms and the school boards right it
was like merrick garland calling these
these school moms uh you know domestic
terrorists
yeah you know i guess i could see that i
i see the escalation there because like
2016 to 2020 was like trump's a fascist
refused fascism
antifa calling out saying that you know
this is the second coming of adolf
hitler referring to trump but that was
like the rhetoric of the extremists on
the left like on the ground right
because i hear that i'm like that's
nothing new
but i guess now hearing it like
officially from like the top democrat
i think in the white house is is the
rhetoric goes from antifa black lives
matter these psychos on the left i think
that's a testament to who's really
behind him right now which is it's not a
surprise right
like this use of the term fascists is
kind of insane because what do you what
do you call fascism corporate government
collusion i mean that's like mussolini's
fascism when the state and corporations
come together for the greater
empowerment of the state we've got the
fbi is working with facebook with all
the social media companies we've got
slave labor in china where we're getting
our clothing from like it's the system
is fascist we're built on a fascist
system we're all semi-fascist because
we're participating in it
so you know but they're end of story
quit blaming people for it well there
are people who oppose it then biden is
actively in it while accusing you of
doing i'd like to know what their
opposition really entails because
speaking out against it but then still
doing it is not an opposition it's it's
foe it's it's you know if anything it's
hypocritical yeah but it's only fascism
like technically to them if it's coming
directly from the government like
they're circumnavigating that by you
know even with the the zuckerberg thing
like i disagree like the the they're
cheering on the feds
it's only fascism if it opposes them
and it could like literally anything you
could be a kid selling candy bars and
then be like you're dumb and they'll be
like fascists
yeah i mean you've got the fbi raiding
the former president's home
unprecedented you've got coveted
lockdowns and they're still calling you
the dude who's like can i cut someone's
hair i'm a barber no you're a fascist
it's like desantis too that's like
charlie crist is going with that
narrative desantis is a fascist well
charlie chris called him a dictator and
you see that he called him a dictator a
couple days ago and he was like
just like dude i was lifting the
measures i was trying to let people
troubleshoot their lives trump wasn't
calling out the military during the
riots which many people thought he
should have i think he should have the
day too i thought he should have i
actually told you that day two is like
this is going to get out of control
national guard in there right now there
are still too many people
who think they can convince fascists
that they're not fascists you know what
i mean they're like you called me a
fascist but but i'm not i swear bro the
half these people they know full well
you're not a fascist you're not going to
convince them donald trump trying to win
over the mainstream media is just
laughably dumb like he's giving them
interviews he's giving and then what do
they do every single time they lie about
him they smear him and he keeps doing it
yeah it kind of like goes backwards on
his initial like fake news
you know swipes
2015 and on but you know what's
interesting about about this claim
you know semi-fascism you know according
to the white house claim about mega
republicans i just love
how these people wrap everyone in this
title what does that mean you know the
black the blacks right the black mega
republicans the brown mega republicans
all the minorities get wrapped in one
like the it's just so mind-blowing that
these are the same people that are like
oh we're anti-racist and we're gonna
defeat white supremacy we're gonna
defeat systemic racism but you know what
let's just wrap all of you in one little
freaking box and put you in one little
fascist box you're the enemies you mega
black you're the enemy you mega brown
that's the rhetoric of these people yeah
and like i just i people need to wake up
because it's like dude stop believing
that the
it's literally like an agenda like
people need to understand it is a
political tactic to prop themselves up
as the saviors of these races
people need to know that i think a large
component of it is rooted in nothing it
is it is
literally
nothing
when you have a
prominent individuals
who have their roots in nothing they'll
say anything
and so they end up making making videos
where they'll say anything for the sake
of adhering to the cult for example like
on this show for instance um oh i think
it was nina turner
she tweeted out that credit scores were
created in 1989 and they to keep people
poor people poor and it should be
abolished and i said agreed i think the
credit scoring system is bs and should
be gotten rid of yeah absolutely you
want you want to give a loan to somebody
there shouldn't be a credit scoring
system where we have no accountability
to how they how they do it i've i've had
instances where
companies will put a derogatory mark on
my credit i can't do anything about it
screw that and they're and they're bs
yeah she's right and she's a fringe like
she's a very lefty we've we've
criticized her heavily but i'll shout
her after being right but there are many
of these political commentators on the
left will never do that in fact my
favorite example when we did a segment
on conservatives being more attractive
than liberals because science shows it
the young turks insulted me called me
ugly and then went but he's right
what was that what was the point of that
i don't think being concerned it doesn't
make you more attractive it's that
attractive people tend towards
conservatism because they're happy with
the status quo because they're getting
things given exactly exactly and that
was what we were saying it's it's it's
idea of privilege because these people
claimed that like working out and being
healthy is like a symbol of white
supremacy
now they're now they're upset about it
that people have privilege or whatever
what really bothers me about this is
this divide and conquer mentality of
like the the mega republicans being evil
is like it's what mao's communist
uprising did in china's they had the red
class and the black class and it was
like if you were a communist in the
party you were red and if you were you
know not then you were part of this
black class and the other kids at the
school would know and they would make
fun of the kids whose parents were in
the black and so they had like the way
to get entrance into the red class which
was the okay one is you'd have to turn
someone in or return your parents this
is what they're doing it's a cult this
is it it feels like that it's a divide
and conquer and it's really low i mean
either low intelligence strategy or or
it's insidious and it's on purpose i
can't i can't figure it out i just want
to shout out one of the funniest things
i've seen in a long time was
hassan [ __ ]
getting doing a video review of a song
we released two years ago will of the
people where he was saying it was wrong
and it was like he called it awesome but
i don't know if he was saying that was
like ironic or whatever but he was
criticizing it saying it was just not
good and stuff like that
and the comments were people saying i
actually liked that song i have it in my
playlist oh no i didn't realize that was
tim poole and that's the funny thing
about it you like the song the song is
good the message is good and then you
found out it was from me and then you
got mad and didn't like it
that's a cult no they got mad and they
still liked it maybe but they have to
tell it is this the thing right
nickelback for instance a great example
of this
if if look man i just got to say
one day someone held up a sign that said
rahm emanuel likes nickelback and then
all of a sudden nickelback became banned
non-gratos like
if you like nickelback you're not fun
you're not cool you're a loser even
though they have multiple top 10 hits as
i have to say not my jam but clearly
people like it if they were number one
for four weeks straight which is kind of
crazy it's like that's a feat to perform
but all these leftists are like
nickelback is dumb nickelback is dumb
because all they know how to do is
parrot each other and say what is
acceptable a good example when i was the
battle for berkeley not the battle a
battle for berkeley there were many of
them
and i was staying on the street with my
my gopro and my gimbal and i was filming
some woman walked up to me and started
talking about all of this stuff
and then i asked her a woman got knocked
down to the ground and had her head
cracked open did she deserve that and
she said well she shouldn't have been
supporting trump and i said so you think
because she supported trump it was okay
people just gonna attack her she's like
yes and then i was like so if like a
woman was wearing skimpy clothes and
walked into a bunch of men and they
attacked her it'd be her fault and she
goes
yeah and then i was like okay then a few
minutes like she like we leave like she
walks away we wrap up she walks back
over and she's like delete it delete it
she said things that weren't approved by
the mob i blurred her face i don't have
any interest in you know getting her
life destroyed but it was clear that
when you try to interview many of these
people they don't do it and this is
exactly why the the exact reason why the
left will not come out onto this show
but conservatives will do it all day and
night is because conservatives are
individualists who have their own ideas
and the left are in a cult and they
don't know what's approved and what's
not i feel like that even goes toward
like to what joe rogan was saying in his
endorsement of republicans
it's like i you might lean left or be
more independent but
you know these people that are going
like all or nothing it's like i might
lean that way but to call everybody a
mag of republican who you disagree with
is just evil and and i can't support
that what is mega republican anyways
these are these the people that voted
that think trump won the election and
they voted for trump well is this a new
term like in this context at least
getting away from trump's supporter no i
think mega republican just refers to
the the new right
like it's a problem
there are people that are like trump's
my president i love trump like those
people you know cultism in general is
pretty bad you don't really want to be
fall into a cult of any kind
but
you know just because you voted for
donald trump or you have questions about
the election doesn't make you like a
cult it doesn't make you a call right
right now you have to vote for somebody
if you're going to vote right now that
my republicans are split between trump
and desantis
on the left they all marched in lockstep
behind joe biden and still post insane
defenses of him granted i understand the
leftists don't like joe biden but they
all made videos talking about why you
had to vote for him which is crazy joe
biden was establishment donald trump was
anti-establishment if you claim to be a
revolutionary who supported the
establishment
for what reason
the argument for
if you were a leftist who want a
revolution trump was your guy he was
destroying everything wasn't he he was
going to fire the bureaucratic state and
purge the civil servants for what good
reason would you defend the
establishment unless you're lying and
you're a reactionary fascist who wants
to turn the clock the clock back to the
1950s and create racial segregation as
one example it's like if they never told
them so it's like their superpower
though right like they you know we split
our our support among these candidates
they hate the right or they hate trump
more than we love you know one one like
group or our ideologies or our freedoms
or like isn't that like a superpower
that they have i think they genuinely
hate black and brown people um i mean
even my run in with katie hobbs on
saturday like i typically don't do
content like that but it just was so
necessary because people need to
understand she's running for governor of
arizona as a democrat right she's
literally a convicted racist like two
times she discriminated against black
people so i go to this arizona put on by
the arizona democrat party her little
event where she's speaking she's
pointing the finger at republicans
republicans are this republicans or that
and here i am as a brown guy just
standing up and asking her a question
hey well what about you katie why don't
you explain to the people about you
being a convicted racist because you
literally discriminated against black
people and who are the ones that got up
in immediately literally put hands on me
and escorted me escorted me physically
out of the building they deported me
it was the woke whites the woke whites
are the ones who immediately go after me
put hands on me and i'm like are you
guys really doing this right now like
the the the the democrats of arizona are
deporting a person of color they're
deporting a latino because i'm calling
out katie hobbs racist record yeah what
did she do exactly so during her a
little administration when she was you
know in in office i think a senator i
believe
she literally
um
a black woman was working for her miss
adams
and she discovered that her white
colleagues were making more money than
she was
so she came out and called it out and
asked some questions and said why
okay and apparently she went on a paid
leave or a paid vacation that was
already scheduled and during that
vacation she was fired let go wow so she
clapped back
sued them and she won okay this is just
one of them she won i think it was like
three million dollars but it was capped
at 300k or something right
so katie hobbs is a convicted
discrimination discriminator against
black people okay so the reason why i
bring this up is like if katie hobbs was
a republican this would be headline news
everywhere if katie hobbs had an r next
to her name
i would have done the same thing same
scenario
and i would have been hailed a champion
and i probably would have been invited
on cnn to come out and talk about it
tonight
the point i'm trying to make is i i make
these points because we all get this i
know tim this is just like simple basic
stuff but i know there are people out
there that that do not even understand
how this simulation works how is it that
i can't do that as a brown man that
these people claim they champion and we
don't want to deport hispanics but the
moment i come out and i call out a
legitimate a legitimate case of racism
but because she has a d next to her name
she gets a pass and the brown guy gets
deported because they're the real racist
i just it's a point to say it's a cult
these people do not care about us they
do not care about brown people they do
not care about black people they only
care about their power and how they're
perceived in the moment and if they can
get you in the cult
bend the knee that's the culture they
want to build i had a guy message me
uh over the weekend and he said that the
reason he hates me he posted a comment
is because i'm shattering consensus
reality
and i was like wow like you just come
out and admit it like you're aware that
you're in a cult and you're mad that i'm
waking people up is that it so it wasn't
that you said anything that was you know
factually wrong it was that you were
breaking what do you call it consensus
reality they you in order to keep people
trapped you have to lie keep them in the
dark and don't let them see the light
and that's why people like brian stelter
he was like don't go and watch fox news
that's propaganda fear if you went and
watched fear watch tucker carlson for
instance you might be like he's kind of
a dick but he's right like he he says
here's the thing and then you're like
let me check thing you're like oh thing
is true he kind of delivers it in a
snarky way sometimes a lot of people
like it you know he's a big show some
people might not like it but he's not
wrong he's wrong sometimes everybody is
but that's that's the issue they don't
want you being able to see any of that
stuff yeah i think it's the metaphor i
keep feeling is like if there's a
governor of a city that's about to be
invaded the governor tells everyone hey
everything's going to be fine make sure
everyone wakes up there's no fear of
anything all that thing you heard about
invasion is just it's just rumors and
then when the city is invaded the people
are still there they defend the city
they win as opposed to a governor that's
like hey everyone we're going to be
invaded and everyone freaks out and
flees the city then when the city's
invaded it's conquered so they think
that they're lying as justified because
it's keeping people calm and that maybe
when we transfer to this new world order
that the americans stability will remain
because we didn't panic but you've got
to see that the lying is causing people
to panic i'm sorry interruption no it's
always fear it's always like everything
that's why everything's a phobia
is attached to everything transphobia
homophobia
if it's not that it's some kind of virus
that's going to come and kill everyone
but what about the virus no we don't
need to know it's the same thing jim
jones did
right the jonestown cult right i was
listening to this uh some some
audiobooks on the way in and i was just
like kind of making the parallels like
this jim jones operated through fear it
was pure fear he like in the in the
jonestown cult like every night they
would have like the white nights where
every single night he would
psychologically prepare them to die and
to suicide themselves for him every
single night like he he would come hey
tonight's the night tonight's the night
we're gonna do he would push it entirely
and he was psychologically engineering
them through fear every single night
every single oh but no no this was just
a test until finally that night came
where they all were willing and ready to
suicide themselves because it was
literally fear thanks for checking out
this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in monday through
friday at 8 pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8 pm and we'll see you all
there
you